good morning John it's Friday a few
weeks ago a company called visually
emailed me and was like hey Hank if you
could do a high-quality animated video
on any issue in the world what would you
choose now that was a hard choice but I
went with incarceration in America
because it is messed up now crime is
also messed up bad things happen to good
people and that's terrible and something
should be done about it
well we send people to prison to be
punished and to prevent them from doing
bad things again and to deter others
from breaking the law punishment
Corrections and deterrence now we have
this habit of thinking of prisoners as
something very external to society after
all there are literal walls between them
and society walls capped with razor wire
watched over by people with guns but
millions of prisoners are released each
year today's prisoners are tomorrow's
neighbors so Corrections should probably
be the most important piece of the
incarceration pie unfortunately it is
not we are however really good at
punishment America has about 4 percent
of the world's people at about 25% of
the world's incarcerated people we have
the highest incarceration rate in the
world over the last thirty years that
number has skyrocketed increasing over
400% forty-one percent of American
juveniles and young adults have been
arrested by the time they turned 23
children as young as 13 years old have
been sentenced to die in prison and our
prisons violate international standards
solitary confinement increases
instability and violence and inmates and
is considered by international law to be
torture but in America it's not
regulated by anyone except the prison
officials no judge no jury arguably the
most devastating form of punishment we
enact in this country and yet there is
no appeals process and you think it's
hard to get a job in America well we
make it intentionally more difficult to
get a job once you have a conviction on
your record not to mention just to live
your life convicts are ineligible for
welfare student loans public housing
food stamps and are often socially
disconnected from community and family
support structures so in addition to
having high recidivism rates they have
very high rates of homelessness and
suicide somewhere along the way
we started to think that being tough on
crime had meant being tough on criminals
but that's not the same thing
punishment is only one piece of a much
larger crime reduction pie and it's an
expensive one with some institutions
paying more than $100,000 per year per
prisoner long prison sentences have
helped to decrease crime but no more
than 25% of the decrease we've seen can
be attributed to incarceration and it
costs far beyond just dollars the cost
is to people to our country to
communities to families and to ourselves
the policy seems to be if you've
committed a felony we just give up on
you these wars on crime wars on drugs
they are wars on people the smart
political move is to appear tough on
crime because crime is scary so we
increased minimum sentences we arrested
more people we sent more of them to
prison that's how we looked tough on
crime but the results are in it's bad
policy it's cruel it's short-sighted and
to continue this policy of mass
incarceration would be foolish we're
living inside of a massive 75 billion
dollar per year failed experiment 2010
was the first year in nearly 40 years
that the number of incarcerated
individuals in America did not increase
policymakers are beginning to realize
the magnitude of this failure but there
is a long way to go John I'll see you on
Tuesday